ah yes did you know that crime in the
90s was double it is now dude
like when you go to Oakland you look at
the graphs and I know this because I
watch YouTube videos of cities
and if you do it you will see crime was
crazy bad in the 90s
the 80s people were serial killing and
now there's like by at any given moment
there's 50 serial killers at large in
America how the [ __ ] do I know that
I watch YouTube videos
there's one in Albuquerque right now
oh really yeah why because Albuquerque
because it's a [ __ ]
there's also one in Long Island there's
also one in Alaska apparently people get
murdered in Alaska at an alarming rate
isn't that crazy dude it's one of the
most dangerous places and it's because
they've got 12 cops dude
not because it's necessarily so bad but
because they got 12 cops and the sun
doesn't even come out
you best believe I'd be murdering that
way
for real dude just ask him I'm joining
the eskimos dude
I'm joining the eskimos if I move to
Alaska dude to me that's like prison you
join the gang I'm and all of a sudden
you won't see past my immediate features
dude I'm joining the eskimos and not
only are they teaching me stuff I'm
teaching them stuff too it's a symbiotic
relationship dude and we [ __ ] show up
to like
goings-on and problems and also like
places where there might be conflict and
[Music]
Eskimo
like this dude you dude my pocket and my
[ __ ] furry [ __ ] is so
it's so cinched
look this is all you see is my nose that
right there could barely breathe I pass
out a lot too they're like this they're
like what what happened Chris what
happened and they gotta uncinch it and I
go
oh sorry I I have my uh I did it like I
was like Kenny from [ __ ] South Park
come on we have to go
okay okay
here's some salmon belly
[Laughter]
here's some salmon belly do I what do I
do do I eat it no put it in your armpits
for good luck oh really yes and warmth
oh okay I don't know
anyway we've got to go to town hall and
murder no one will catch us
so um
so yeah
so we go to [ __ ] uh so yeah anyways
Alaska but crime has been crime was
terrible the gank I I subscribed to hood
vlogs
better believe it dude and gangsters the
most gangster thing you're probably the
most gangster thing is like Robin and
stealing and shooting [ __ ] but
it's not you know what being the most
gangster [ __ ] is is being the absolute
most positive guy ever being the most
positive guy and loving your kids so
much and still be running the block Like
It's Hot seriously
dude when you watch these Hood Vlogs
there's always like one or two gang
members that's like you know I mean this
is the hood but like I'm always trying
to get up out the hood that's the thing
man like the hood is a mentality and the
hood is a lifestyle and you know I yeah
I I you know it's it's a rough life and
I don't want it for my kids I don't wish
it on anybody I don't wish it on my
worst enemies man but then they always
pepper something in like but if they
come across here and they're not
supposed to I'll kick their [ __ ] ass
and push their way back but I will say
though man like I don't you know I don't
wish this lifestyle in anybody but they
should call us if they're coming across
this block because we'll [ __ ] light
them up like the 4th of July anyway
but they're so positive this is my
daughter you know and you're just
holding the kid what's up
you want to go play in a car okay you
wanna go play in the sprinkler okay
watch out for bullets
but it's so gangster to be so positive
um
yeah
it's crazy to go I want to go to South
Central a little bit and just poke my
head and how wide is that dude how
[ __ ] privileged is that I just want
to check it out
want to drive by in what car I want to
drive by and just [ __ ] see what's up
dude I pretty much I pretty much want to
do that
I've been shot at once I've never told
that story on this podcast by the way
I've [ __ ] straight up have been shot
at how crazy is that and I it some
things you just forget for long enough
that they're gone but I've straight up
been shot at
this was probably
15
years ago probably
15 years ago
um I was seeing this girl and she was
like come over I had never been over her
place
um
and she was like
come over and I said okay I'll come over
this time
to this day
I have no idea what area it was in like
like for real I couldn't tell you if it
was Northwest East [ __ ] south or it
could have she it could have been up I
have no idea
and
she's like so it's not the best
neighborhood but park if you can get a
space if not you know they do the whole
thing where it's like I got an extra
spot but I'll have to move and the thing
and the Tandem and you're like all right
I'll just you know
I'll find a spot so what does your boy
do your boy Parks Parks illegally
so I park illegally and only a little
bit illegally like my back [ __ ] bumper
is peeking out with the and hitting the
red
and I'm walking over I can't even
believe how much I don't know where this
was
I wish I knew like did I take the 101 or
the 405 or the 10 and then which way did
I go was it on the way to Barstow like I
have no [ __ ] idea so I'm walking and
I hear
and I'm just I go whoa and I'm like oh
and I don't even register what it even
might be I just
think sounds are happening like I'm 28
and it's not even like oh did something
pop did a tire get flat why are there
two of those and I'm certainly not
thinking oh a gunshot
so I'm like wow what was that and like
that [ __ ] idiot who saw the deer I
just stand
and I'm looking around
and then I hear
Pat
and as I'm like is that good
I get to there
is that
gunshots I get to is that G and I hear
listen
and I go what the [ __ ] was that
and then I go fast walk to where she
lives and she lets me in
and I feel myself saying it's not like I
even decided to say it it's just like
whoops oh oopsie Daisy we're already on
the roller coaster of talking and I
guess this is what we're saying and I
said I I think I just got shot at and as
I say that she says yeah
it's a bad neighborhood but you're all
good just stay here
and I'll never forget this dude
she was awesome and we just hung out for
a little bit and then she you know
made me feel Sensations we'll say
for the
niceness of YouTube and she made me feel
Sensations and then I said why are you
so good at that and she said I don't
know I usually
she said I usually date Republicans and
surprise the [ __ ] out of them
that's what you said how my mother
forget it congratulations
[Music]
[Music]